my question for the globalists and Davos
is are you people really the Masters of
the Universe or not because you present
yourselves as the Masters of the
Universe who through your own unfettered
reason your Brilliance the likes of
which we've never seen in all of history
Aristotle Plato Thomas Aquinas those
guys are all dummies compared to you you
all figured it out you've mastered the
future you're going to conquer death
you're gonna you're going to go in
you're gonna edit our genes you're gonna
recreate Humanity not just culture but
our very biology okay if you want me to
trust you to do that then you better be
able to live up to those promises that
you that you shall be as Gods so can you
stop a virus outbreak I see no evidence
of that in fact from the behavior of
these sorts of globalists I see them
exacerbating a lot more problems than
they're fixing are you the Masters of
the Universe or not
if you're not that's fine I don't think
you're the Masters of the Universe
but then stop messing with our societies